I painfully have to admit that I I
cannot understand it and I don't have a
good explanation to give to you I take
Europe Europe was saved by America
Europe today is more threatened then the
namerica by this very dangerous trend of
Muslim extremism just a few days ago we
had the terror attack in London in
English go this was not the first one
you had the ones we had in in Madrid so
europeans are subject or have been
subject not less than americans add to
that the fact that in Europe you have
significant Muslim minorities that are
being incited by those radical Islamists
in different ways through the internet
through special TV stations operated
either with the support of Iran or or
independently and they are creating a
major problem for Europe itself in terms
of how their own Muslim population will
integrate or not integrate into their
own societies Iran is now developing
missiles that would easily hit Europe so
having said all that you would have
expected first Europe's would be much
more cooperative and responsible in
addressing the threats and much more
appreciative of the United States
behavior leadership in this context so i
guess that's what i did was sharing with
you my frustration but i'm afraid i did
not give you a good enough explanation
to a behavior i fail to understand